this video is brought to you by
squarespace the tool to use if you need
to make a website for your brand or
business more about them in a bit
as the crowds took their seat in the
arena they saw a small young woman walk
onto the stage holding a rifle upside
down on the table in front of her were
five other shotguns husband threw a
glass ball in the air which was
immediately shattered about upside down
shot from the rifle as another two more
balls went up into the air the woman
quickly picked up one of the shotguns
and turned them both to dust then two
more went up and she shot them with
another shotgun and then again
and again six guns eleven shattered
balls later the woman bowed and blew a
kiss to the audience smoking shotgun
still in hand the duration of this
entire performance only 10 seconds the
shooter was none other than annie oakley
arguably the most famous woman in
america during her heyday she had just
performed a show-stopper that she had
many other tricks up her sleeve she
could hit a target behind her by aiming
at it using a handheld mirror or even
the shiny blade of a table knife
alternatively she could have turned
around cited and shot a moving target in
half a second she was the greatest
sharpshooter of her day maybe
of all time she certainly was the most
celebrated thanks mainly to a
long-standing act with buffalo bill's
incredibly popular while west show and
even though annie oakley herself was
never actually a cowgirl living out on
the american frontier the association
had transformed her into one of the most
iconic figures of the old west
[Music]
annie oakley was born phoebe ann mosey
sometimes spelled moses on august 13
1860 on a farm outside the tiny remote
village of woodland dark county ohio so
nowhere near the actual wild west her
parents both quakers were jacob mosey
and susan wise and she had eight other
siblings although two died as infants
even in her youth everyone called phoebe
and annie but she wouldn't adopt the
name oakley until later in life when she
began her stage career from a young age
annie was a bit of a tomboy who often
preferred to explore the outdoors and
climb trees with her brother or help her
father around the farm instead of sewing
clothes or playing with dolls with her
sisters unfortunately she only enjoyed a
few carefree years before tragedy struck
and annie's family found themselves in
dire straits jacob mosey was three
decades older than his wife he was 61
when annie was born and he died of an
illness when she turned six to make
matters worse annie's older sibling her
sister mary jane died of tuberculosis
less than a year later and the family
was so strapped for cash that her mother
had to sell the family cow pink to pay
for the funeral expenses the family was
hurting but they didn't have time to
grieve since they had lost their main
provider the matriarch susan mosey had
to sell the family farm and rent a
smaller place annie still a young kid
helped out by doing chores around the
house which meant that she only attended
school sporadically even so annie wanted
to do more while alive her father had
been an avid trapper and hunter were
often provided for the family by going
out into the woods outside the farm with
his snares and rifle and he watched him
hunt on numerous occasions and so she
asked herself
how hard can it be her first attempt
didn't go too well then he fired a shot
but the kickback from the rifle knocked
her on her behind no big deal she simply
loaded too much gunpowder danny got up
and tried again and again and after some
practice she got comfortable with the
gun in her hand and started hunting
small game to help feed the family
already it became pretty clear that
annie was a natural when it came to
shooting when it felt right i just
pulled the trigger is how she explained
her prowess with firearms despite a
newfound source of sustenance courtesy
of annie it wasn't enough to feed the
entire family therefore although it
pained her to do so susan mosey had no
choice but to send some of her children
away the youngest offspring were taken
in by some of the neighbors but
nine-year-old annie was sent to the
county poor farm in the nearby city of
greenville the poor farm which everybody
called the infirmary took in not only
the destitute but also orphans and
people with mental problems annie didn't
spend a lot of time at the infirmary
because one day a friendly farmer came
in looking for a young girl to help
around the house after his wife had a
baby he promised a modest salary and
that the girl would be able to attend
school it seemed like the ideal position
for annie at last she thought that a ray
of sunshine had come into her dreary
existence but in reality she was about
to enter the darkest chapter of her life
in later years annie refused to identify
the couple by name only referring to
them as the wolves they might have
appeared friendly but behind closed
doors they were a pair of cruel and
sadistic abusers who basically kept
annie as a slave and worked her to the
bone this was her regular schedule get
up at 4am make breakfast milk the cows
wash the dishes skim the milk feed the
pigs and carves pump water for the
cattle feed the chickens rock the baby
to sleep work in the garden pick wild
berries and get dinner on and as a
reminder here annie was only 10 years
old at this point the grueling work was
complemented by physical and emotional
abuse although annie never wanted to get
into specifics about what had happened
to her at the farm she mentioned that
she had plenty of scars and welts on her
back from the wolves and the wife was no
better than the farmer annie recalled
one occasion when she fell asleep while
doing chores so the she-wolf punished
her by locking her outside in the winter
snow completely barefoot she would have
probably frozen to death if the farmer
hadn't arrived home and let her inside
annie endured almost two years of this
barbaric treatment until she finally
found the opportunity to run away she
made her way back to the infirmary which
by this point was run by samuel and
nancy ann eddington who were friends of
manny's mother they let annie live with
them and sent her to school with their
own children and suffice to say they
were the opposite of the wolves the
other kids teased dany by calling her
topsy because she showed all her teeth
when she smiled but annie didn't mind it
had been a long time since she had any
cause to smile when she was 15 and he
finally made her way back to her mother
who had remarried and moved to the
village of north star ohio her older
sisters were married too so even though
she had just returned home annie had to
figure out what her life plans were
going to be she worked various odd jobs
while living with the eddingtons but
there was only one thing that annie was
truly good at shooting so she turned to
a shopkeeper named katzenberger who
owned the general store in greenville
and struck a deal to supply him with all
the game that she could hunt she became
a market hunter as they would call back
then and from that point on annie oakley
spent the rest of her life earning a
living with her gun
now just before we continue today i've
got to tell you about a service that
you've probably never ever heard of
before squarespace just joking look
everyone knows about squarespace and
that's because they are the absolute
best place to build a website since also
because they've got lots of ads telling
you about squarespace but seriously they
are the best if you need a website in
this modern era there is no better place
to go if you've ever thought for any
reason i need a website for something
don't even think any more about it just
go to squarespace.com why because
squarespace websites are ridiculously
easy to make and super feature rich even
if you know nothing about websites
you've maybe just been around the
internet being like oh these one this
one looks pretty that one functions
really well well that is the sort of
website you can make with squarespace
even if you know absolutely nothing
about making websites plus it's not just
blogs which of course they do
beautifully you can also sell things
through squarespace which you know it's
good if you've got a business or maybe
just want to sell memberships to your
online cat yoga class that's a business
as well we're not saying your business
is good we're just saying that you you
could do it with squarespace plus email
campaigns analytics social integrations
all of that usual stuff that you would
expect head to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com forward
slash biographics to save 10 of your
first purchase of a website or a domain
and now back to today's video
[Music]
this new arrangement only lasted for a
year or so but it was enough to lead to
annie's proudest moment so far when she
saved enough money to pay off the
mortgage on her mother's house in
northstar susan mosey had already been
widowed a second time so once again she
was hurting financially then when she
was 16 annie got a letter from her older
sister lydia who was married and living
in cincinnati inviting her to come visit
or according to some versions asking her
to move there permanently at first manny
was a bit apprehensive after all farm
life away from the hustle and bustle of
the big city was all she had known but
with a little encouragement from her
mother she agreed cincinnati was only 80
miles away from her home but for annie
it was like stepping into an entirely
different world all the lights the noise
the excitement crowds of people
everywhere she looked giant hotels fancy
restaurants not to mention all the
steamers that made their way down the
ohio river annie fell in love with
cincinnati and stayed there for a few
years until one friendly shooting
contest won a not only a prize but also
a husband now this is a major event in
annie oakley's life but to be honest
we're not really sure when it happened
and neither is anyone else not even the
people who were involved gave the same
account of where and when it occurred if
we are allowed to dish a tasty bit of
19th century gossip it may be that the
discrepancies in years were caused by
annie herself in a bout of vanity and
jealousy during her time with buffalo
bill's wild west show she developed a
rivalry with another female sharpshooter
named lillian smith who was 11 years
younger than her one day annie decided
to turn back the hands of time on her
life and lopped six years off of her age
permanently causing chaos and confusion
for her future biographers anyway
historians placed the contest sometime
between 1875 and 1881 so just pick
whatever year sounds better for you at
some point during those years the cells
brother circus passed through cincinnati
one of their acts was frank butler an
irish immigrant who was an exhibition
shooter he bragged that there were only
two other living men who were more
skilled than him with a gun but in
cincinnati he had rumors of some
greenville local who would gladly take
him to school if he was willing to bet a
hundred dollars easy money thought frank
butler and in a few days time he made
his way to the town by the time he
arrived word of the contest had already
spread and half the locals turned up
ready to show their support for the
shooter unbeknownst to butler annie had
built up quite a reputation for herself
over the last couple of years but
we'll let him tell the story i got there
late and found the whole town in fact
most of the county out ready to bet me
or my friends to a stand still on their
unknown i did not bet ascent you may bet
however that i almost dropped dead when
a little slim girl in a short dress
stepped out to the mark with me i was a
beaten man the moment she appeared for i
was taken off guard never were the birds
so hard for two shooters as they flew
from us but never did a person make more
impossible shots than did that little
girl she killed 23 and i killed 21. it
was her first big match my first defeat
there's probably some embellishment
there butler after all was a
braggadocious showman and promoter but
the point was still the same annie won
and frank lost frank didn't care though
he was in love and annie too was smitten
with her opponent a year later the
gun-singing duo got married
after time or not frank butler resumed
touring and his shooting act but
contrary to what you might expect he and
annie didn't start performing as a duo
immediately butler already had a partner
a man named john graham and together
they build themselves as america's own
rifle team and champion all around shots
not very catchy we know but the act
itself was thrilling enough to lure in
the audiences their centerpiece
performance involved the two men
shooting apples off of each other's
heads butler did it by turning around
and bending over backwards while graham
did it by turning around bending
forwards and shooting upside down
between his legs at some point likely in
1882 annie joined the tour but only as a
spectator chance played a big role in
her life and one night graham became ill
and couldn't do the act quick to
improvise butler brought annie on stage
with him but only to hold up objects so
that he could shoot them butler said it
was his habit to miss a few shots on
purpose to get the crowd worked up but
on that occasion he just kept on missing
one shot after another after about a
dozen misses an audience member taunted
butler to let the girl give it a go and
you can probably guess what happened
annie hit her mark the first time to the
raucous cheers of the crowd and butler
could spot a good act when he saw it
from graham and butler it soon became
butler and oakley and soon enough just
oakley with her husband serving as
manager and stage helper frank butler
had the sense to step aside and let
annie take the spotlight when it became
clear that she was the big money maker
speaking of oakley the name itself is a
bit of a mystery danny was fiercely
private about her personal life so she
never made it really clear where she got
the name from the most obvious and
boring answer is that she took it from a
neighborhood named oakley which is in
cincinnati but a more fanciful tale says
that oakley was the name of the
benefactor who paid for a train ticket
and helped yongani escape from the
wolves anyway butler and oakley did
their act a few years including a
one-year stint back with the cells
brothers circus it was at this time that
annie forged a most famous friendship
the one that would become an integral
part of her legacy the one with sue
chief sitting bull the story is probably
half true half legend but we'll offer
you the version presented by annie
herself she and butler were in minnesota
most likely saint paul at the same time
as sitting bull the lakota chief was one
of the most notorious men in the country
following the battle of little bighorn
and although he was a captive he was
allowed to tour the nation and make
money from photo op souvenirs etc and
shameless plugin coming if you want to
learn the whole story of sitting bull we
have a biographics video ready and
waiting for you just saying anyway both
parties were in the same city so sitting
bull decided to go and see annie oakley
and he became fascinated with her he
sent word to her offering 65 for a
photograph but annie gave him one for
free and promised to come and visit him
the following morning when they finally
met face-to-face sitting bull was so
enthralled with her that he insisted
upon adopting her christening her
ortanya sisler or little sure shot at
least that's the story annie and frank
put forward they recognized the
marketing value of a rebranding so from
that point forward annie oakley was
billed as little sure shot with their
contract with the cell's brother's
circus expired frank and annie thought
that they would try to go for the big
time and in the world of travelling
shows there was no bigger than buffalo
bills while west oakley met with bill
cody and his business partner nate
salisbury in 1884 but she left
disappointed buffalo bill already had a
shooting act captain adam begardes and
his four young sons danny oakley was
still small-time compared to him so cody
had no reason to choose her but soon
enough they played her hand again in
late 1884 the steamboat carrying the
wild west crown equipment was heading to
new orleans when it collided with
another steamer and sank there were no
casualties but bergard has lost his
equipment and suffered some damage to
his equilibrium which never got better
in march 1885 he left buffalo bill's
show at that point oakley approached
cody again and offered to do three shows
for free as an audition and with nothing
to lose bill said well what the hell and
accept it
[Music]
ry with her first performance it became
immediately clear to bill cody that
annie oakley was destined to become a
star unsurprisingly bill signed her to a
deal immediately and the two embarked on
a 17-year long business relationship
that saw them travel up and down the
country as well as across the atlantic
to perform in front of the kings and
queens of europe becoming particularly
popular in england the prince of wales
even organized a shooting contest
between annie oakley and the grand duke
michael of russia who fancied himself
quite a marksman a contest that danny
obviously won oakley and cody got along
well for the most part and he described
buffalo bill as one of the nicest men in
the world while cody wrote of oakley
that she was the loveliest and truest
little woman both in heart and aim in
all the world occasionally their
relationship got frostier allegedly
because buffalo bill was jealous that
oakley's fame rivaled or even surpassed
his own but and he never made such
accusations ultimately as her desire to
settle down that persuaded her to
gradually step away from the limelight
for a large chunk of their careers annie
and frank lived out of a tent always
ready to pack up and move to the next
place finally in 1892 they bought some
land in nutley new jersey and started
building a house of their own from then
on annie worked part-time for bill cody
half the year she spent touring with his
show the other half she spent doing the
other things that struck her fancy she
and frank never had kids but they
enjoyed doting on their many nieces and
nephews she also worked with charities
that helped orphans and other needy
children and annie personally took it
and educated at least 18 young girls
from poor backgrounds annie oakley
believed that shooting wasn't just a
man's game and it was important for
women to learn it too she spent a lot of
time offering free classes especially in
her later years and she may have taught
upwards of 15 000 women how to shoot at
one point in the lead-up to the
spanish-american war she even wrote to
president william mckinley offering to
train a regiment of lady sharpshooters
she repeated her offer during world war
one but never received a reply annie
oakley's career took a drastic turn in
1901. it was october 28th and the wild
west show had staged another successful
production in charlotte north carolina
and was on its way to danville virginia
for annie and frank it was supposed to
be the last show of the year before they
got to go home and rest up so they were
in good spirits near lexington the
unattentive conductor of a freight train
missed the signal to move the tracks and
placed his train on a head-on collision
course with the one transporting the
wild west show fortunately the other
conductor was a bit more watchful he saw
the incoming disaster and ground his
train to a halt the two still crashed
but the impact was a fraction of the
catastrophe it could have been no humans
were killed although 100 of buffalo
bill's horses broke their legs not to be
put down annie got hit pretty badly the
sudden jolt launched her out of her bed
violently she cut up her right leg and
suffered internal injuries and paralysis
on her left side she was taken to the
hospital but needed multiple operations
and months of rehab to recuperate and he
retired from bill's show following the
accident she thought that she was saying
goodbye to the stage forever but she had
a change of heart in 1902 oakley starred
in a play called the western girl
written especially for her which still
featured plenty of sharp-shooting tricks
but not so much physical activity and of
course she still partook in the
occasional shooting contest or
exhibition she would never abandon those
until the day she died in 1903 oakley
took on a new challenge the media after
one of william randolph hearst's
newspapers published an article claiming
that annie oakley was an addict who got
arrested for stealing a man's pants to
feed her habit the story was picked up
nationwide but it was grade a fake news
the arrested woman simply gave her name
as annie oakley both papers published
attractions but this was not good enough
for annie who prided herself on being a
lady she dedicated the next six years of
her life to suing all of those
newspapers for libel she won 54 out of
55 cases her only defeat being against
the richmond news ledger in 1911 with
the court cases out of the way annie
oakley enjoyed one last hurrah joining
the young buffalo wild west show which
wasn't affiliated with buffalo bill in
any way she stayed with them for two
years giving her last performance on
october 4th 1913 in marion illinois
afterwards she retired from the stage
and rode off into the sunset building
with frank a new home in hambrook's bay
maryland danny had saved enough money
and now got to enjoy her twilight years
in peace by 1926 both she and frank
butler were in poor health she was
suffering from a blood disorder called
pernicious anemia annie oakley died on
the 3rd of november 1926 age 66 frank
died 18 days later and was buried next
to his wife of 50 years
[Music]
you